michael pineda making his 20th start of
the season
last pitch
this past weekend against the blue jays
hopefully we see the same consistency
from big mike as we've seen all season
the wind up and the first pitch he's
swinging a fly ball center field
playable buxton back on the grass
drifting calling catching and springer
flies out not overpowering and simeon
alliance a fastball into center for a
base hit price stayed back very very
well on that slider and just kind of put
a nice smooth swing on it
high fly center field
and guerrero like springer tried to
ambush pineda
tap her
simmons
to
short
on the heel of his glove still got the
flip to polanco and a quick first inning
for michael pineda steven has been on
quite a role he is 4-0 in his last seven
starts with a 272 earned run average for
the season
he has pitched pretty well this is his
28th stunt
and a base hit to laugh
buckson battling fouling two strike
pitches off he ends up grounding a
single to left field to start the inning
that's hit to center and hit pretty well
and grichik is there to catch the line
drive one away it might be a good time
to change the eye playing for donaldson
and he did exactly that
great call buck a curveball to get him
swinging for out number two
driven hard to left center field that's
a base head buttson going to third
drawing a throw
and he's in safely
garber stinging the ball again another
solid hit to center field first and
third two down and that'll bring up
kepler
another curve and he'll finish it off
that way kepler fires away the bat after
being worked over by steven matz
he leaves runners on the corners and the
game stays scoreless as we go to the
second oscar hernandez lourdes gorilla
jr randall grichik coming to the plate
milling his arm around say oscar lines
with a right center good contact and
it's down for a base hit cut off by
buxton t oscar digging for second and
he's in there as the throw skips past
simmons at the bag so a lead off double
for hernandez here in the second and
here's lourdes guriel jr
he got a breaking ball over the middle
of the plate and he lines it into left
center hernandez will come in to score
easily guriel will take his place out at
second and the blue jays have a one to
nothing lead well that'll tie in with
kelly gruber for the most runs in
september in franchise history with 30.
and now he's just five behind josh
donaldson and edwin encarnacion for the
franchise record in a month at 35 and
that's a spin and hanging breaking ball
and the way he's swinging right now you
can't fool him anything that's left up
out over the plate a breaking ball meant
to be down and away he's going to hit
his heart
and high fat small gets the job done
first and second one down for danny
jansen
tapper to short
one
save it first twins will take a look at
it but from up here it looked like he
beat it out no twins are going to
challenge it it's not even close he's
out looks like he's out doesn't it
double play
so the twins
in the inning byron buxton with the
ground ball single to left his first
time up
drilled to left how many bases
rounding first digging for second the
throw from durielle
not in time
feet first sliding double for byron
buxton to begin the third inning rudder
at second here is jorge polanco who
lined out to center
up the middle and through for a base hit
that'll score buxton and the game is
tied a hot smash right over the mound
and we're tied at one
and for polanco his 91st
run batted in
breaking ball that
was able to just hit it right back where
it came from he does not go and
donaldson takes ball forward
but now first and second and nobody out
for garber
that's just short center not hit well
but hitting a good spot palanco around
third he'll score and garber drives in
the go ahead run
two hits to center for garber
one stung the other flared but the twins
have a 2-1 lead still nobody out in the
third
space head left field
donaldson will be held at third so
they're loaded up now for rooker
and that one is in there a change-up
catches the inside corner to freeze
rooker for out number two
and mats will strike gordon out to end
the inning to the plate here in the
fourth inning with taos hernandez
against michael pineda
and a swinging a fly ball to left field
towards the corner goes gordon and it is
gone
first pitch swinging and that is number
30 for te oscar hernandez and just like
that the blue jays have tied it well
what a pretty swing that was on a
breaking ball and the only question was
whether or not it was going to stay fair
and the oscar he's two for two he's
scored a couple of runs he's driven in a
row now he's got 110 rbis and he's going
to sport that jacket first one tonight
and abujas have tied it up josh
donaldson will lead off the fifth inning
for the twins and he takes up high for a
leadoff walk and here's a guy swinging a
hot back carver he has two hits tonight
driven in one of the two runs
to the gap in left center
really stung one hopping the wall
donaldson to third he'll be held
and carver continues to rack up hits
three tonight
and the twins are in business second and
third with nobody out in the family and
lourdes goriel jr is still down in the
outfield he went into the alley going
after that ball grichik is the one who
played it but something has happened to
guriel
does randall come over and step on his
hand yep that's exactly what happened
randall in his follow-through was behind
guriel and watch his right foot come
around and gurious planted on the ground
and then randall steps right on top of
his hand looks like lourdes is going to
have to come out of this game and this
is really unfortunate for a guy who has
been as hot as anybody over the last
couple of months so it's second and
third nobody out very good contact
hitter with the plate and luis arise and
that'll get a run in donaldson racing
home on a rise putting it in play and
putting the twins in front three to two
so meriwether will come in let's have a
lead but there are two out there on the
bases with two out and he'll face nick
gordon
a high drive
to right field hernandez back it is gone
nick gordon's fourth of the year with
two men aboard and the twins break it
open in the fifth you can see nick
not a big muscular guy
but he has some pop in that back
and that ball is a no doubter
[Applause]
a three-run home run a four-run twins
lead
so now danny jansen will come up jansen
has grounded into a double play and
popped up base hit left field
dickerson around third they're gonna
hold him up he's coming through the stop
sign and he is out
ran right through the stop sign and a
rise threw him out at the plate elias
tries his ball perfect made a great
throw
dickerson you know not a bad slide but
never oh his foot actually kicked the
glove so he never really got to the
plate
to down and now brent rooker
fly to right and deep and go off the
facing of the
uh plaza area there and rookers in with
a double
off the limestone in front of the
extended seats in right field and rooker
with two down bangs a double the
opposite way twins lead six to two and
let's see if they can cash in now with
gordon
and now gordon rolls a base hit to
center how much more can he do tonight
three hits four runs batted in and two
hits against left-handed pitching 27
blue jays two and scars is back out here
in the ninth inning
bouncer to third donaldson waits
high throw over to her strong throw i
should say over to sono one away
breaking ball got him two down it's a
nasty slider a strike three to vladimir
guerrero rounded to third donaldson's
got it and that will do it and the twins
buck dropped the blue jays a game back
at the yankees for the second wild card
spot